Joe rated Mar-A-Lago with the feds now
he gets a taste of his own meds that's
good
[Applause]
the White House admits that more
classified documents were found this
time at one of Biden's homes in Delaware
and in his garage but it's cool man
because that garage was totally locked
okay classified classified material next
to your Corvette what were you thinking
let me uh look I'm going to get a chance
to speak on all this God willing soon
but as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvettes in
the lock garage okay so it's not like
you're sitting out in the street but
anyway
yes as well as my Corvette
well someone really wants you to know
that he owns a Corvette
also the Corvettes
all right Viagra commercial
[Laughter]
but it's all good no one has ever broken
into a locked garage before well that's
impossible and it's not like people
leave that giant garage door open from
time to time like when they get that
Corvette out
you know I'm thinking we should store
our nuclear bombs there
Merrick Garland announced uh justice
Department's appointing a special
counsel to review whether Biden
mishandled classified info so how is the
White House dealing with this come on
just got to trust the process
this is an ongoing process under the
review of the Department of Justice
we're going to respect the process and
we're just going to allow the process to
continue process process the process let
the process continue it's an ongoing
process I am genuinely saying to you
there is an ongoing process this is all
part of the justice department process
as part of that process and I said
because there was a process of Justice
throughout this process we just laid out
the process that was taken and that is
the process
just trust the process which is what I
told Janet Yellen when I gave her that
haircut
[Laughter]
now
obviously the White House is going to
deflect it defend oh they were in a
secure location the door was locked he
didn't know he was vice president
and it's no surprise the media is on
board with that right Joy
there are differences in what happens so
not good well we all know that Trump is
a liar and a thief you know
a bigger jump to say that he obstructed
and he lied we don't think that Biden is
a liar and a thief so we give him the
benefit of the doubt I've never seen a
luckier person than Donald Trump just as
we're this close to getting them but you
don't know
translation if I keep Shilling for Biden
they keep feeding me pudding
fun fact her defense required a special
microphone so we could hear Joy talking
out of her ass
it's also worth noting that the first
set of documents found at the Penn Biden
Center reminds every one of the
connections between Hunter Biden and
China even Ben Carson couldn't separate
those two
yeah I like that FYI after the Center
opened the Biden Center the school
raised Millions from China and tripled
foreign donations I'm sure it wasn't a
kickback right Joe
come on I I can't deal with this right
now
I didn't I can't even read that
classified stuff without my reading
glasses
and I might have had a classified in
there but I didn't have any uh maybe one
secret no top secret
and I definitely didn't have any of that
uh crossed my heart hope to die
or stick a needle in my eye
I don't even do that anymore I used to
you know whose eyes stuck in Needle in
Corn Pop
Pirates do you think Biden is receiving
the same treatment Trump was given
sure yeah
a thousand percent
um well you know we can't compare the
two it's apple and oranges one of the
president who has the right to do it he
was a VP yeah and I'm losing my mind
they're acting like he brought them home
last weekend
wasn't there another president in
between the time he was vice president
and now so that's at least four years
plus the year so he's had these for
almost six years and everyone's acting
like it was last weekend doesn't that
kind of mean something and then now all
of a sudden it's coming out and
literally to Behar you can't even quote
her but
literally why he was giving a speech
explaining the first one
and admit his speeches are tough to
follow but he was very specific that it
was just one thing at the bottom of the
screen while he was giving the speech
the second batch was found
and then today why he was explaining the
second batch
the third batch was found
the only defense I will have for him is
I get it hiding stuff in your car
for married men it's our safe it's where
we keep things we don't want her to know
about that's why we keep our car just
dirty enough to where we always take
hers
like she'll go to your car like oh the
front seat's full of coffee cups and I'm
not getting in there just take my car
you're right dear
so probably what happened was is that
Jill said hey I want to ride in the
Corvette no
no I'll clean it up myself and
he took the stuff out and that's how he
got caught your car is your safe so I I
get it I get it get a bigger car buy it
yes this is a this is hilarious it's
just what's so great about this it's not
so much about the documents but that he
was such a self-righteous ass about
Trump and now it's he's getting the
payback he deserves can I just point out
one small thing that in all of this at
the Penn Biden Center he was the
Benjamin Franklin presidential practice
Professor yeah Ben Franklin Joe Biden I
don't think so no
one invented electricity and the other
one causes it when he when he rubs his
hand in girl's hair
I'm helping you
they liked it no I'm not saying that's
sad because it's true yes I I have to
say you know Kat do you think him
putting these documents in next to his
court vet has anything to do with his
oil cancer
yeah
yeah he's got I can't believe he has a
Corvette when he has oil cancer and yeah
he never lies though Joey Behar he never
lies so he really has oil cancer he
really was raised by Puerto Ricans like
he really is Jewish all the stuff that
he just says yeah he'll lie like shut up
I
heard differences for example they did
say hey we found these Trump didn't do
that but I saw this article the New York
Times that was like here's the
differences between Biden and Trump's
and I thought it was going to be an
article about the differences but it was
limited to all the ways in which the
differences make Biden look better than
Trump right of course rather than oh hey
to me the most insane the craziest I
think we should all be the most pissed
off about is that all of us should be
pissed that we didn't they found these
before a week before the midterms and we
don't find out about it until now I
don't care who you are as you should be
able to vote with as much information
that is that you can regardless of what
your party is we should everyone should
be pissed off about that and a lot of
people are ignoring that foreign
do you think this special counsel is
just for show
probably I mean they don't they want
they have to make it look like they
would do for Biden what they did for
Trump except I don't recall they didn't
raid his garage did they uh no this was
all a voluntary episode based on the
fact that he had been caught I I'm still
struck by the fact that it tells you
everything you need to know about the
ivy league today that the University of
Pennsylvania thought it was a good idea
to give a think tank to the single
dumbest guy
[Applause]
that is true and
and they even you look at the emails
that came off of Hunter's laptop they
said well we're good this is the Clinton
foreign initiative without having to
raise money uh underneath it and what do
they do they institutionally raised
almost 100 million dollars from Chinese
sources when Joe Biden showed up and
what might those documents be for and
you raised the right point at the
beginning Donald Trump was the president
having the power to declassify Joe Biden
wasn't this should be a real problem for
him the timing is the story do the Dems
want him out because yeah
on the Republican side no no this is an
inside I I made the mistake you heard me
I think it was on Tuesday where I said
Kamala do something yeah and she did it
apparently she watches the show so
that's all she does
that's true I gotta watch what I say her
and mayor Peter behind the whole thing
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else